ja ich bin wieder da ich nehme aber
gerade auf mama ich nehme gerade auf du
brauchst jetzt nicht reinkommen
hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einer runde survival james und zwar
diese total fertig aus ich habe hier das
sind so politik sonst immer so halt nur
zum aufnehmen und zum chillen habe der
und der türkise wenn ich den und
integriert sind an habe oder seine roten
sitzen reißverschlüssen habe ich ja
nicht nur an um aufzunehmen einfach so
schwierig so vor pc bisschen schön
die sache ist die ich war gestern auf
dem geburtstag und ich war mega besoffen
und ich war um 6 zu hause ich war nicht
zu hause beim kumpel gepennt will habe
ich sogar ich kann mich an sehr wenig
erinnern es war egal ich weiß nicht ob
wir alle so schon erfahrung mit alkohol
habt ihr könnt eure top stories in die
katarische whatsapp stehen dazu wieder
zugesperrt hier erst mal kurz aus
jedenfalls baut man ja ein promille in
zehn stunden ab wie jeder in der
fahrschule lernt wenn ich in der schule
war und die sache ist halt die ich hatte
200 promille locker mindestens oder 5000
ich weiß nich dann hab ich jetzt halt
noch 4999 weil ich hab das letzte
letzten wort gar um 6 uhr getrunken und
jetzt ist es gerade 12 uhr
und ja ich hatte ein bisschen wenig
schlaf und ich dachte jetzt einfach alle
von euch wollten dass ich eine
verkaterte runde immer aufnehmen weil
ich ja fast jedes wochenende eigentlich
weg bin
sebastian lkw wie weiß das ja und
ja ich dachte jetzt einfach dass ich
jetzt eine runde zwei games auf nehme
ich hab' ich habe gar keinen druck
erster fehler ich muss immer den
kopfhörer einstecken
ich weiß auch gar nicht ob ich ein
server können wir denn jetzt gehen wo
kann man denn so können wir denn jetzt
irgendwas mal spielen wir können ja mal
auf mein us von plex dot com haben die
überhaupt survival gamestar ich weiß es
gar nicht wir können auch etwas anderes
einfach spielen können auch dieses dings
wir tun und wir tun einfach so als wäre
das zuweisen games also ich war gerade
joggen das beste ist wirklich wenn ihr
das ist lukas auf tipps was ist das
alles drin
oder wir spielen dragon dass kate hätten
mehr bock da komm ich bin gegen sk
einige von euch die wollen ja immer dass
ich mal oder payback sagt nein und
gesund ich ein gamer card dragons regan
smith because they brought möchte
paintball da super paintball ich weiß
nicht wie paintball funktioniert ach so
ja noch ein bisschen wie super pace in
progress ach so ja gut
konkreter hast du nach deinem namen
geschriebene ich in franken wie das geht
ja doch die game but don't quit next
game will be starting zu bekämpfen sich
halt zwei seiten glaube ich es liegen
keine ahnung hallo hallo was im kopf
nicht so hängen ach das sind so leute
sind mitspieler oder den kopf hängen
wahrscheinlich zwei verschiedene teams
die müssen sich dann halt so bekämpfen
mit schneebällen oder was hat der titel
einer hand hat er deine hand
flaschen uns das alles keine ahnung ich
wollte halt nur viele leute haben mir
gesagt dass ich mal besoffen was
aufnehmen soll ich habe jetzt halt ich
bin jetzt nicht richtig besoffen weil
ich ja enorm haus nicht an bin ich denke
man hört auch gar nicht mehr ich habe
mich an wie sonst nur mit ein bisschen
nach einem raueren stimme sie müssen
fertige aus die fans kammer jahr gar
nicht hier eingestellt also tut mir leid
wenn der focus ein bisschen komisch ist
man wie lange geht das noch
das braucht halt dass audi noch jahre
noch von jeder von jedem leuten leben
noch zwei
also das sind die leichen von den leuten
wenn den thema bewegen
von jeder von jedem leuten leben noch
zwei das kann ja eigentlich mehr so
lange dauern
was machen wir hier eigentlich
wo sind eigentlich die anderen beiden
das gefühl jetzt auf einmal wieder dabei
wir können ja mit
wir können ja mal versuchen dass wir
irgendwo in anderen räumen der winter
jetzt nicht verlangt von superpunk bauen
das auf dem spiel
ach mensch wir können gar nicht spielen
anscheinend in jeder spielen sondern
clever dragons super paintball super
paper
das ging gerade los verdammt das ist
voll das fell video gerade ich glaub ich
glaube ich schneide jetzt einfach mal
raus bis ich im spiel drin bin
hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einer runde wo ich ein bisschen besoffen
rum spiele und zwar habe ich gerade
schon fünf minuten aufgenommen aber ich
habe nicht aufgenommen ich habe überlegt
den club gibt einfach gedacht ich nehme
einfach nur ausgerichtet und ich habe
halt nicht den knopf gedrückt für die
aufnahme also ich sehe bin ich lege das
gartenfest ich bin total fertig ich war
gestern auf dem geburtstag und ich hatte
locker 200 millionen promille und da man
ein prominent zehn stunden abbaut habe
ich circa bisher 0 3 promille abgebaut
ich war penn deswegen bin ich halt
eigentlich schon wieder relativ fit ich
war halt auch schon joggen und so was
alles ein bisschen ausnüchtern halt und
viele von euch meint nicht einmal
verkatert aufnehmen welche richtig auf
bei facebook postet wöchentlich so jungs
ich bin gerne in der lage video
aufzunehmen oder irgend sowas teilweise
nicht möchte halt nicht so wenn ich dann
so drauf bin was aufnehmen also ich bin
zwar gut drauf aber nicht wenn ich so
von der körperlichen verfassung so bin
ich weiß ja wie so was feiert ihr könnt
mir habe eure auf geschichten die
kommentare schreiben
da sage ich so komische sachen wieder ne
ich wollte den kumpel von mir heißt
calvin und ich denke jetzt mal nachnamen
aus und also sagen wir mal heißt müller
mit nachnamen und ich habe einem anderen
kumpel von mir der heißt fabio den mann
ansprach notiz gesendet bei whatsapp 11
mio viele liebe grüße von calvin peter
und ich habe einfach falsche nachnamen
gedacht ich lasse so richtig viele grüße
ganz richtig heißt nicht peter das
erzähle und ihr heute das erst nachher
an und ist lacht keiner mit mir das ein
bisschen traurig naja jedenfalls wollte
ich besoffen jetzt hier ein bisschen was
aufnehmen also ich bin ja eigentlich
nicht mehr das offen
ich bin ja nur noch so ein bisschen
angetrunken bin hat dabei
allerdings ihr skript das ist alles im
spiel drin ist ein programm ach ja da
sind scripts und die müssen sich dann
abschließend ja das kenne ich das gerne
jetzt auf jeden fall ist er sehr geil
aber irgendwer muss 20 kills haben damit
damit dass hier losgehen kann ich denke
da kann man auch risiken
da die opfer musste ins wasser durch
pizza isst er blöd meinte wir müssen
ich wollte jetzt einfach nur weil viele
das immer meinten ob in progress ist
alles im programm komm ich jetzt ins
rutschen kam rein
aber ich bin jetzt besoffene switch
router was heißt besoffen also ich bin
am aus richtern und den immer noch
besoffen aber ich bin noch dabei den
alkohol abzubauen
deswegen möchte tier mal sowas dass ich
so was mal öfters machen jedes
wochenende weiß ich nicht vielleicht
möchte dass ihr euch zum beispiel nicht
cool mir so was einmal möglich ist ja
wenn ihr neues video seht von daher
keine ahnung kannst ja geändert und ich
war halt joggen und mir war so kalt mein
ganzer bauch hat sich auf den kopf
gestellt beim joggen ein kumpel von mir
spielt hawke nach zweiten bundesliga und
der wald auch mal so von hat am nächsten
tag ein hockeyspiel und ist einfach
zusammengeklappt weil der halt das
irgendwie nicht mehr hingekriegt hat von
dem links von der körperlichen
verfassung
ich habe jetzt gar keinen plan wie das
in irgendeiner form funktioniert
ich glaube ich kann ich mir nicht
irgendwo das team
joão dias finden schreibt semperoper
das wm ticket
geht's los hier bestehen noch und
douglas wie dragon verspielen wir denn
überhaupt spielen dragon escape alter
wäre ich komme gar nicht klar mit dieser
bewegung hier dass es geht mir grade
alles viel zu schnell ich lasse die
anderen erstmal vor laufen
ich werde jetzt entstehen wieder so
facebook dienste von crafter lässt beim
rennen alle anderen vor laufen will ich
wirklich dachte ich wäre schon tausend
mal tot
ich lasse ich erst mal vor jungs heil
runtergekommen
ja ich bin wieder da ich nehme aber
gerade auf mama ich nehme gerade auf du
brauchst jetzt nicht reinkommen ja ciao
weil sie nicht einer halben stunde so
nähe brauchst du nicht das waren meine
mutter skechers typs das mega geil man
hat so halt so wie geht das eigentlich
kann ich mich nicht immer mal die
steuerung dann gucken snipers kipplaster
das kit ghana
naja ich hab noch welche warte ich geb
dir geben muss meine mutter recht
gegeben
ich sage ich weiß nicht kann ja sein
dass ihr so etwas mit wenn ich einfach
so mega verplant bin
steht doch jetzt sind wir besser wo ich
hin schieße ich bin einmal schon
gestorben ich hab ein getötet 2 k s habe
ich schon 3
leute sport doch mal vielleicht hier
bisschen da
6 ich bin zweiter
7 ich bin erster ich weiß gar nicht ich
die schneller schwimmen kann
oh scheiße
je mehr leute hallo hallo jungs ja
irgendwie schneller schwimmen oder so
ich sehe auch gar nicht die liste ist
gegen die weg wer wieviel leben wer
wieviel getötet hat vielleicht gewinne
ich das ja auch wie krass wert beträgt
das gewinnen würde besoffen
es ist ärgerlich wenn ja wird noch mal
stehen jetzt hier treffen wir nichts
mehr
ich sehe auch diese liste da nicht mehr
alter wie können wir auf einmal immer so
plötzlich gas geben
aha mit schiff geht das mit schiff kann
man so schneller schwimmen
es muss sich ja gar nicht dass ja cool
hier sagt mir das denn ihr kleiner
wieder welche fahne beschossen
ich wusste ja gar nicht
oder thailand
erst mal stehen hier
man schwimme alle vorneweg die blöden
dort holt ich wurde nur dritter es ist
und man nicht aktiv wird erster gut
conny hdf freude das war's eigentlich
will ich ja gar kein video aus sonnen
einfach wieder posten das ich nicht kann
weil ich ja echt lecker fertig bin
naja ich hoffe alles gefallen lässt euch
gefallen dann könnt ihr den daumen hoch
da lassen
wer jetzt duschen und danach welche ins
kino gehen und was hat jetzt noch so
vorschreibt meine kommentare ja dann
wollt ihr mehr so was ist nicht dass man
ihnen diese mache dass sich aufnehmen
egal in welchem zustand meine hände sind
so kalt kalt gefroren weil ich war
joggen und in kurzer hose und bla und ja
leute ich würde sagen
laufen ist gut